you
the power core is strained to the
breaking point we can recharge the
shield's but they still won't last long
the hyperdrive has been completely burnt
out enemies on the fleet their boots
Emily's there would have been telling
backup controls here but the enemy ships
ever surrounded we have few options left
we save as many lives as we can
attention shields are failing and the
enemy has a surrounded
evacuate now while you still can
so be it
you've awakened I trust you can walk
unlock these shackles and I'll show you
exactly what I'm capable of you and
heart of our Empire now I assure you
escape is impossible even she could make
it past me come along
what Empire have we entered the eternal
Empire the cool you didn't even know
whose territory you invading
some outposts nearby were destroyed not
long ago your handiwork we tested your
strength you seem to have suffered for
it less than your people did
Prince Arcan find a docking sequence
initiated
we recovered the records from your
ship's computers or what was left of
them fascinating reading you civ
apparently quite formidable you most of
all to alter the course of galactic
offense as you have quite impressive you
don't need to be impressed with what
I've done you need to be afraid of what
I'm going to do yes we'll soon know
which are truly capable of Prince Arcan
hesco still waiting for the catastrophe
that you and your Saiyans foretold you
may close your ears to the whispers of
fate my prince but they cannot be
silenced I wonder if silencing you might
suffice to get superstitions elsewhere
school you are not needed here your
followers don't seem to be as sure of
your invincibility as you are own
important relics with unfounded beliefs
don't be swayed by their nonsense is
this why you brought us to here you
[ __ ] with soothsayers come along
you're taking us to your master I'm
taking you to my father Val corian the
immortal emperor of the pool and Emperor
just what we were searching for you will
not find what you wanted here
his glorious Majesty immortal master and
protector of zaku Emperor valve corian
welcome a new name a new face these are
not enough to hide from us the Sith
Emperor your presence is unmistakable oh
I think a mistake has been made but by
whom
this thing you call Emperor is nothing
but a murder he will kill every last one
of you to fuel his supposed immortality
he's already tried once your constant
silence across our history this was your
distraction this was my focus everything
else a means to an end you claim to have
come all this way to find me Here I am
what do you want to destroy you once and
for all you say you know me if that is
true then you know the depths of my
power whatever you hoped to achieve here
you know deep inside that you cannot
succeed but you do not have to stand
against me instead you can kneel I will
never again near to you
you would sooner die than acknowledge my
superiority it is you who fears death
that Korea I do not I will not kneel
Oh
clear the room everyone out
mar gave the Empire leadership while you
used us for your own game you are
nothing compared to him he was narrow
mind bound by a relevant ancient Dhamma
but I think you are different in all my
centuries you'll own have merited my
full attention you leave your mark upon
the galaxy wherever you act just as I do
look around you the pool is poised to
become the greatest civilization in the
history of the galaxy I have forged this
Empire to surmount all of my previous
works to span the eternity the eternal
throne commands a fleet more fast than
any ever built it has the power do we
shape the galaxy into any image that I
choose that we choose i will share all
this with you if you were only kneel
you
you